hey everyone welcome back to the swish
woodland podcast where today i am joined
by one of the games great who is of
course on swish so exciting opportunity
for you all this legend who i thought
would be sitting around that 300 mark on
there is only for just fifty dollars and
add to that the new water discount which
is fifteen dollars off and we are
sitting at thirty five dollars for a
personalized video message from one of
the best to ever do it also up to 70 of
those proceeds go to kiwi kids charities
and it is super easy to use i'll leave a
link in the description so you can just
go click on that and get a message from
one of the absolute greats of the game
also before we start i have a message
from another lad tim bateman with a very
exciting opportunity for all waterled
listeners cheers jimmy are you looking
for an exciting career for life after
rugby my name's tim bateman and i've
been a professional rugby player for the
last 17 years
my plan for life after rugby was to get
into the well-being and recovery
industry so i built ostudio new
zealand's largest well-being and
recovery centre
despite the challenges of covert we've
seen consistent growth in our business
and we've decided to expand ostudio
throughout new zealand and abroad
it's an exciting time for the wellbeing
industry and we're looking for top lads
to be a part of it by opening your own o
studio
if you're interested head to ostudio dot
co dot nz slash lad to inquire back to
the show
[Music]
oh what a lad well it's always good to
have a genuine legend on the podcast and
to be honest they do not get much better
than today's guest he's a proud otago
man and potentially the greatest
highlander of all time having played 153
times for them including captaining them
to the 2015
super rugby title he's also a
commonwealth games gold medal winner
with the new zealand sevens and of
course a rugby world cup winner with the
all blacks he is an incredible player
and even a better lad it is one of the
greats it is ben smith welcome mate
thanks jeremy thanks for having me on
that would hurt to say that
what a year that was for you boys your
boys were incredible that yeah
yeah we just managed to get a bit of
momentum and
yeah two white battlers at the back
going out in the bottom of himself and
the man himself
mate but awesome to have you on um
obviously been a massive fan of yours as
a player throughout my career and your
name's popped up heaps of times
throughout all the other podcasts so i'm
looking forward to hearing some of the
stories from your side of the view yeah
yeah hopefully give a couple stories
yeah
i really enjoyed my rugby over the years
and hopefully
yeah but we'll start with the current
you obviously just come back from japan
how was it over there yeah it was
actually uh it was good the
borders are starting to open so managed
to get over there not do the two weeks
when i got there all the two weeks when
i got home so
uh yeah normally that's a month of
isolation and yeah yeah i actually this
time i went over without the family so
they stayed in school back over here and
uh yeah managed to play a couple of
games i only played sort of three games
but
i really enjoyed uh my time over there
obviously uh
the passing of cumbi uh steve cumberland
was uh pretty sad while we're over there
and
uh yeah in a way lucky enough to get
over and and
uh
have some memories of playing golf with
him and um
yeah sharing some time over there uh
before the yeah the sudden shock of him
passing away yeah that was incredibly
sad yeah so how did your um how did the
gig come about were you sort of
expecting a gig were you training were
yeah i thought you were retired um yeah
well i think most people thought are
outside the club i think
so i was always signed for this season
but uh our fellow had just a little
heart issue and with the borders the way
they were
i wasn't keen to leave nz and then not
be able to get back because family
weren't going to go so
i sort of said oh well i'm not keen to
go with the chance that he might need um
some medical care and things like that
so i think the club found that easier
just to say that i've retired and
that's what happened and then when i
sort of said all the borders are opening
up now we fellows seem to
be going pretty good i said i'm going to
get back and um and finish off the
season so that's sort of how that worked
out but the club i think
it was an easier way for them just to
say i've retired and they probably
didn't think i was coming back so that's
how that sort of played out mate so you
were still training uh thinking that
you're going to go back there yeah like
to be fair the borders looked i didn't
look like it was going to open up so i
was doing about it running gym wise
not a whole lot so
um never been massive on the gym but um
yeah i was definitely doing a wee bit of
running and things like that but so i've
got i got a couple of weeks when i got
over there we had a bye week the
following week so it sort of gave me a
few weeks to
yeah to get ready for uh the japanese
league yeah and you didn't play a heck
of a lot i mean it's pretty hard now
with the foreign rule there only being
four foreigners allowed on the field
but every time you did get an
opportunity um you obviously played
extremely well still got it
oh look i thought that's a hard game to
give up so i really enjoyed getting back
over and playing unfortunately for cruds
he
got
his achilles were pretty tight in the
last few games but that meant that uh
yeah i mean playing ended up playing
center with uh lucano who was uh it was
good value actually he really enjoyed
uh getting over there playing alongside
him and uh getting to know him too top
third and
yeah i really enjoyed those last few
weeks when i was there so then everyone
wants to know about a million questions
came in about this what what's next for
you uh have you hung up the boots or are
you still looking for gigs um
yeah at the moment i'm just i'm going to
weigh everything up and then i don't
want to say i'm retired because then i
sort of i set myself up for failure so
i'll just i'll i'll sit on it for a bit
and then oh you never know i suppose i'm
getting older i look 45 but i'm 35 but
um
yeah hopefully
if there's an opportunity that pops up
we'll weigh it up then and go from there
yeah so how is the body feeling it's
actually feeling uh bloody good like i
haven't played a whole lot of rugby over
the last couple of years and yeah i
really
enjoyed the games i played over there
and that's actually i think that time
just to give it a bit of a rest uh has
served me pretty well so i hadn't hadn't
done a lot of weights when i got over
the obviously but running wise i was uh
still
probably just at where i was from the
last evening season if not a wee bit
better so
uh yeah so the the body is actually
feeling pretty good but um yeah we'll
see what happens so if the highlanders
came calling uh for the quarter final
would you be stepping up no no no we'll
sort it over there though um
no i've done my time with behind this
but i'll be supporting the boys and
hopefully uh get a chance to
knock over the blues we'll be underdogs
i would say but um you never know like
uh yeah a bloody good game and the fact
that we just got to turn up and play
very well in the night and we'll be a
chance yeah mate you've done it before
yeah we have yeah just a bit of momentum
that's all we need to put a momentum and
away we go but uh yeah i'll definitely
be rallying them behind behind us as we
go forward into the playoffs hopefully
yeah so and what about for otago would
you potentially look at playing for
otago on the bunnings cup uh so at the
moment uh they've just got like a wider
training group where i'm going along and
just doing away with the coaching uh
because tom don leaves away with the
under 20s and a couple other coaches so
i'm just
getting along there and just helping out
on a wednesday night so
uh yeah i'm sort of quite keen just to
poke my nose into into that sort of
space and and hopefully just uh pass on
a wee bit of
uh my learnings and and things i've
picked up over the years uh and there's
a good bunch of fellows that are meeting
on a wednesday night that obviously work
through the week and then uh go on to
trainings and play club footy in the
weekend so they're probably not guys
that have got contracts at the moment
but that are trying to get one so i'm
quite enjoying that yeah so would you
put the beats on there
no at the stage no no yeah oh you never
know but at this stage um i'm full on
we've got three kids uh i'm coaching
both both of uh
uh annabelle and wally's
team so
that's that's pretty full on um and and
doing them on a saturday and uh yeah
i sort of don't want to miss uh watching
their games uh as well so yeah you never
know i'll see you see what happens and
then that last one would be a japan gig
that's probably the most likely one
isn't it when the big japan uh clubs
come calling for you again is that the
one you're a lot more likely to take um
yeah to be fair i think the states is a
a pretty interesting one for us as a
family i think
uh it's just hard because we've got a we
feel like it's uh seven months uh vinnie
who
yeah he's still not sleeping through the
night or anything like that so uh he's a
big job for katie so
i'll yeah we'll see how he checks but um
yeah if katie said let's let's do it
let's go over then i'd be keen as much
to get over and try the states it looks
like a pretty awesome competition there
and a growing competition that's um
yeah that's that's good to watch so yeah
you never know yeah mate a lot of guys
are going over there right have you
heard from anyone over there how much
they're enjoying it or anything yeah
well i heard from tom franklin actually
he went over and played in san diego i
think himself dan pryor i think
they just sort of said right we want a
place by the beach we want a couple of
surfboards give us a wee bit of money to
get by each week and we'll be there and
so they signed uh
over in san diego and when he came back
he said he loved it so sure
uh yeah he's definitely selling the
american dream over there yeah so it's
not it's not really a money thing it's
more of a lifestyle thing so obviously
the japan sort of where you got the the
money perks but is it in america you've
got a lifestyle sort of gig that's what
you're chasing yeah i think it's a
different different way of life over
there and a lifestyle thing as you said
i think that's why most of the kiwi guys
are actually doing a bit of both now but
in japan and the states and obviously
europe um yeah there's definitely a
growing contingent of kiwis over in the
states really enjoying it and i think
you know with the i saw the states the
other day got the world cup yeah you
know in a in a few years time so i think
the game's only going to grow and i
think that uh that league will grow too
definitely and you've already mentioned
you're getting into the coaching side of
things is that where it would go
um into a player then player coach into
a coach yeah i'm not i'm not 100 sure if
that's for me or not but i just sort of
i try it i know there's a lot more in
coaching than there is playing the game
i know how uh hard that is i've
you know seen
coaches who get in early in the morning
and and don't leave until sort of six or
seven at night and they're working in
weekends uh
you know working around the clock to
make sure they're prepared if it's not
for the game in the weekend then it's
the following week so
that's not lost on me or how hard that
is and
uh yeah i want to make sure i can
balance with my family doing a wee bit
of rugby coaching and things like that
so i'll see see how that goes mate it's
exciting times exciting times ahead for
you and i can definitely tell you're
definitely not retired there's going to
be gigs
coming out i'll see how we go yeah yeah
are you doing a bit of coaching as well
at the moment yeah i'm at tasman so um
yeah i'm a little bit like yeah i've
just sort of dipped the toes in and um
slowly working my way up but yeah you're
right you do quickly find out how much
coaches do
behind the scenes so that you sort of
take for granted as a player yeah
sitting in front of a screen for a long
time coding things and
doing a bit of admin yeah 100
but anyway it's always good to hear the
stories from the start and keen to hear
how your sort of story started obviously
i'm the legend that you are give us the
rundown of your childhood ah i don't
know about legend but uh yeah i like
baby i had a good upbringing as far as
we lived about 100 meters from the rugby
field so that was a good start
i had a whole lot of kids on our street
that were
uh into either playing rugby cricket
tennis whatever's going really and so
sometimes we're a bit lazy to get down
to the rugby field so we play you know
touch rugby on the street uh try and
dodge a few cards we actually
lived in a dead-end street which
meant that we could get away with it a
bit more
uh had a real good upbringing went to
king's high school
met some good mates and
uh yeah i'd just say that i i fell in
love with the gamer rugby early on and
uh i'd take a rugby ball everywhere
pretty much to uh to keep myself
entertained so yeah a pretty good
upbringing really were were you good at
rugby ah
well my parents early on made it and uh
they sort of went to about under sevens
under eights until they gave me a crack
at it uh i think mum and dad appreciated
their weekends for a couple of years
there and then they decided to throw me
in the mix but uh i was just here
running the mill sort of player um but
enjoyed the game and and slowly chipped
away at trying to get better really and
when did you start thinking this is your
dream or when did you think it was a
possibility to potentially make a career
out of it ah
so it wasn't until so i played for uh
the otago sevens we stay up in
queenstown i don't know if you had that
tournament up there it was awesome so
we got most of the support being otago
between us and otago country we've got a
lot of support up there and so i played
a bit of sevens and uh so i managed to
play
one of the tournaments and then uh from
there i played that tournament and then
a week later the hondas were having a
trial uh just an integral between
uh each other so greg cooper who was the
coach he said come along and just sort
of sit on the bench you know you might
get sort of five minutes and then
uh from there uh craig claire was one of
the fullbacks and so he went down with
five minutes i was like sort of starting
to get up thinking i might get a chance
here
and then uh glenn horton went down as
well
within that must have been 10 minutes so
uh i was sort of the next cab off the
ranks i i got a chance to play in the
trial game and then
managed to get 70 minutes and it was
just one of those things where things
managed to stick uh the bouncer ball
went my way and i'd go straight through
the line and things like that but we've
been a fortune at the time but
that gave me a chance to
get in the under-21s at the time uh we
weren't traveling anywhere but we played
canada after the all blacks played them
uh up in rotorua and
from there sort of things started to
happen and uh got an opportunity to play
for otago which yeah that was that was
interesting uh otago at the time we uh
so we were playing wellington first game
and so they were they were pretty
stacked with all blacks they had
somebody else in jose de paris
i think rodney was playing that
like it was pretty much an all black uh
team at the time yeah uh and so we went
up there for otago and that was my that
was my first game
uh and so we got into it and
i was playing fallback and at the time
it just felt like uh bull rush even sort
of breaking through from everywhere
uh and um
we lost by 70 points and i thought well
that's uh this could be me that could be
my first and last and yeah i remember
cozy bank holes came on and he was sort
of in the same situation while just
trying to get our careers going and
things like that and
i even like he he broke through the line
i can't remember who he stepped but you
know jenkins drives his way over the try
line then he's you know celebrating hot
dogging like he does i was thinking you
know this this couldn't go any worse and
and i'm looking at khalsi there has been
a great old time with his um his debut
so
that was my introduction so i thought
it'd be my first and last but from there
uh i didn't really play the next year uh
steve martin was a coach and he sort of
fair enough chucked me on this uh on the
back burner for a weaver uh and then i i
started getting opportunity from there
true so your pathway from school were
you not in straight into an academy or
anything like that it was just
thrown into this random trial game yeah
so actually
first year out of school i had a coach
that was at uh king's high school who
went over um to bristol and he was
coaching the old colsons collegiate uh
high school over there oh yeah uh which
was a bit of a rugby school so he said
straight out of school he said oh well
um come over here work at the school you
should just do odd jobs and then um pay
for their old boys team which is called
the old folkstonian so my first year out
of school i went and had a gap year over
in bristol which i really enjoyed uh so
i had a full year over there and i just
worked at the school mainly doing pe so
i did a wee bit of pe
uh and then i just fell in gaps really
all over the place so like even uh at
lunchtime uh the receptionist should go
heavy lunch and i'll be answering phone
calls uh at the office
not not being from accounts but um you
know
been from the office
so i'll actually race so we lived close
by to the school yeah uh back to the
house and where we lived i put on you
know my shirt and time things like that
and get along to the reception do that
get back get back in my ideas and then
that was sort of a bit of me and then
we trained twice a week uh real casual
it would be
the equivalent of like a prem too maybe
seniors
out here and
so uh i really enjoyed it though like
they
uh made me feel pretty welcome getting
over there and they just really lived
for
training playing the game in the weekend
and then the biggest one was going to
the club room on a saturday night uh in
the weekends where
uh they'd often stitch me up that have a
you know a point of nasty that what they
called it every weekend where they'd
fill up uh you know put a guinness um
they'd be curry that they'd have uh for
dinner that they'd chuck in upon and i
said they'd give it
they'd give it to the player today at
the time there's a lot of those aussie
bears like the four wrecks and fosters
and things like that and then they'd
fill up a beer and then they'd give it
to the player of the day and i think you
know a lot of the time they thought it
would be funny if they just gave it to
me every time so
um and probably some of the other ones
wouldn't attempt it but i was yeah i was
18 19 at the time and thought i'd been a
bit of stick to stick to the tradition
so
yeah i really really enjoyed my time
over there actually bristol was uh good
and uh yeah thanks to dell patterson
i've got an opportunity over there but
you mentioned uh going into the otago
environment we've already heard stories
from uh craig newbie etc on how sort of
loose it was especially on the past um
playing for otago was it the same when
you went in there yeah early days yeah
noobs was there when i first went in uh
yeah he must have been
he must have had a bit of money back
then because i remember he even paid off
like counting his kid at one point
it must mean after a game he couldn't be
bothered
um picking his bag up and getting his uh
cattle ready so he paid kan hiscope at
the time i think it was like 20 or 30
dollars uh to pack up all his bag and
get him all sorted so that uh he didn't
have to do that after again
but i remember at the time it was like a
um we had a states committee
and so after oh as i said before that
first game against
the um wellington team we decided we'd
go for a bear because myself george
whitelock and brett mader it was our
first games against wellington and we
thought uh we'd just we just lost it was
a heavy loss and but we thought we you
know it was a milestone for us so we
thought we'd go have a beer
but at the time we
had a month and the rule was you just
got to stick to space so
it was pretty pretty big back then that
you made sure that you stick to space uh
and yeah i don't know who it was but we
must have junk in one piece the very
first there we had when we'd gone uh out
after the game we had a montage and i
said i don't know how it was no one
really came forward but yeah that was
called uh
yeah
that meant that the devil was inside us
and we had to um purge the level so
they actually gave it a couple of weeks
until um
they decided that we we needed to get it
out so
that was pretty old still back then and
it wouldn't wouldn't happen now but um
that meant that there was only one way
to sort of get the devil out and that
was drunk's fates until the months had
come out and so
um see cumberland actually at the time
he was watching us then
and he was deciding when that people
would come out and
yeah it was yeah it was just a bit of
old school but um yeah definitely things
have changed in that space we we we did
have a long turnaround but um yeah i
remember brent mayman and george
whitelock and myself we regretted
drinking one piece at the time
and i i do yeah i do know now like even
the hondas and otago like we get given
like a a chart of all the spates and
line nathan products so you can go
through and when you get to a bar you
can say oh well these are the ones that
are you know we we can we can have so
um we didn't have that back then it was
probably a bit silly to drink montes but
um yeah i suppose just that relationship
that we had with states was always
pretty big back then they looked after
otago they looked after the hondas and
it was just a bit of a way to repay them
and
um yeah a little bit of a tradition at
the time but you got the devil out yeah
we did yeah
otago you quite quickly made your way
into the highlanders sort of environment
didn't yeah so took me through that sort
of process yes i was
2007 that we played that wellington game
didn't get a whole lot of game time uh
the rest of that year and then 2008
managed to get a bit more consistency of
games
and so then i made the holidays in 2009
from there and
yeah managed to sort of start the first
couple of games and and i think the big
thing was i found myself rugby was if
you're playing every week it become a
bit easier it became
uh that consistency of playing
overweight gave you a better performance
i found and so
i definitely made heaps of mistakes
early on and there was
monday reviews that i'd go into and
wonder if i'd be playing again in the
weekend because
it was pretty obvious that um it was
definitely uh mistakes and
flaws in my game but i was really lucky
that um glenn moore gave me the chance
to keep playing and and he sort of
showed a lot of faith in me at the time
to keep playing every week and and that
sort of i thought that set me up for
the years to come yeah were you a
confident player or did you always feel
like they have a little bit of doubt
around your game
ah
i think early on it was a real it was a
real interesting period as to whether um
i was up to that level or not like i
felt definitely confident playing club
rugby and
things were going pretty well in that
space and then i suppose every time you
sort of go up a level you
you just i i always sort of took a wee
bit just to figure out that you know i
could i could match it with you know the
players at that time and and the teams
that were going around so
yeah that was definitely learning as i
went through and what was it about the
highlanders sort of culture that you
loved so much yeah sounds like a lot of
kids growing up in dunedin that i went
along to carroll's watch
the likes of brownie and peter lattini
and
jeff wilson brendan laney all those kind
of guys team randall that we just had a
pretty good team to watch when i was
younger so i remember watching them uh
they really enjoyed their rugby they
looked like they got on well and i
remember them you know having different
celebrations when that score tries and
you just watched on thinking you know
that looked like a good environment to
be in and
uh they had their own i think we had the
hollanders had our own way of going
about um playing rugby and in our weeks
and
uh that's what i saw and then obviously
got to be a part of it later on which i
really enjoyed
and you saw when you sort of went into
the environment
probably fair to say that the
highlanders were
struggling a little bit they were always
sort of the lower end of the table but
you were there and sort of turned it
around and obviously got them right to
the top in that 2015. so what was the
turnaround there what did you guys do
yeah so
early on when i was in there we we did
really battle we
would have the odd good game but
consistency of
how we performed as a team wasn't there
so
um what turned it round i think you know
we were lucky enough to like jamie
joseph came in in 2010 2011. and he came
in and bought a bit of i suppose a
hard-nosed approach like we did a lot of
down-ups
and had this mentality that we wanted to
go for 12 rounds uh which was like a
boxing analogy that you know we wanted
to show a lot of fight we might not have
had the talent that some of the other
teams had but we were not going to let
our mates down and we're going to work
hard for each other so that was that was
installed at us from jamie and then
jamie was obviously pretty hard-nosed
but then um tony brown came along and
brownie was
probably on the flip side like the
yangtze james yang and the fact that he
was a lot about um innovation and he was
a big around culture and he was probably
a bit more sort of like work beside you
and and try and work it out together
whereas jamie was very much you know he
was a strong driver of keeping people
accountable not that brownie wasn't but
he would he would often say it how it
was and sort of uh brownie the way that
he was
innovative and things like that it sort
of worked in our favor because
they uh they both managed to sort of
point us in the direction of getting
better as a team uh from there and
uh i think that led to you know we made
the um playoffs uh
we lost in the playoffs but then
uh you know the next few years that set
us up for um winning it in 2015 and we
probably learned a lot when we actually
in 2013 we went and you know jamie went
and recruited a lot of big name all
blacks at the time but we probably
didn't work hard enough on our culture
and
uh what we're about and we probably
relied on uh on that talent of having a
lot of all blacks and that was a good
learning at the time yeah was that the
famous year where you guys were oh yeah
yeah yeah all night it wasn't a good
year um
so we really yeah we really struggled
but the thing was we were
it was tight it wasn't like we were
losing by large margins we moved by
between three and seven points i think
there was like five games in a row where
we'd lose between three and seven points
uh so
yeah that takes its toll
over over those two weeks uh but i think
that actually set us up for 215 because
we we learned what we're about as a team
what our culture was about what our
environment was
uh and i've learned a lot from jamie and
brownie and the fact that if your
culture and your environments right that
your rugby can actually piggyback off
the back of that and there's some things
that you know your culture and your
environment can show it within a game
that you can practice all day long but
um unless those things are right people
won't work hard for each other and when
did you realize in 2015 that you had the
culture
to win a competition
ah yeah i think you know we started to
get a bit of a roll on we played the
chiefs down in indicator no one really
likes uh well especially concerning
teams going down to indicate we'll play
but we really enjoyed getting down there
got a lot of support and we enjoyed
getting down there uh and so we've
managed to sort of i remember waisaki
scoring some freakish trials down there
and then we sort of got away from the
momentum and then we played the cheeks a
couple of weeks later in the quarter
final and beat them again and you could
just feel a bit of momentum coming our
way and i knew
culture and environment was good because
the boys were pretty relaxed in the way
that we were playing it and we sort of
felt like we didn't have a whole lot to
lose because in a way we're probably
underdogs right from the deck of winning
the competition you guys
had beaten us well and truly during the
round-robin stages i know
jerry collins had passed away and and
you guys were pretty fired up to put out
a good performance um and they were
round-robin sort of stages so it's like
the back end of the season we managed to
get that momentum and
that gave us a bit of a chance and then
we beat the waratahs over in sydney yeah
and i i remember a big thing of that was
in the newspaper the day we played it
came out and had how many wallabies they
had in their four pack and how many you
know all blacks we had in ours and i
don't think at the time we had
i don't even know if we had one
but we had a pretty good crew that would
work hard for each other and
uh i remember jamie used that as he was
pretty good i had his motivational speed
speeches and he sort of you know pulled
that out of nowhere just before the game
and you know listed off how what this
reporter had said and that we were not a
chance and things like that and so
uh the forwards had arced up and
and that's how we managed to uh i think
get one over the whitetails that they uh
and then all of a sudden we're in the
final and then
anyone's a chance in a final and yeah
that's that's when we played you boys
yeah and to be fair going into that
final it was pretty much the same if you
compared the teams on paper the probably
only person you'd take from the
highlanders into the hurricanes would be
swap the two full backs and you've got
pretty much the all black squad
but on paper like the
hurricane is stacked i remember you
dropping me in that game actually
i don't normally get in a full uh sort
of fight during the uh the game but i
remember you killing me about it
i was sort of looking over thinking
what's going on here
but what do you remember about that game
like obviously um massive crowd huge
occasion heaps of highlanders fans had
come up
were you always pretty comfortable that
you were going to get the job done i
don't know but comfortable i thought
that where the elliot got that down
i'll tell him that too but um
yeah i remember the week actually was a
pretty good weekend the fact that
everyone from around home was sort of
starting to think about getting tickets
travelling out my parents and
katie's parents and caddy and
annabelle at the time came up
and then there was lashes i don't know
he was making these speeches on a
thursday and friday that would
um they sort of ended up being pretty
legendary and then
uh there was that um was it the
shepherd's arms i think that a whole lot
of people were starting to meet there
before the game and all of a sudden it
was just a lot of excitement about
getting out to wellington and
uh then i got a long time i remember
getting along for the stadium and you
know what it's like at
westback stadium normally you're
chucking a bit of grass up and it's
going everywhere
but uh it was one of those nights where
it was just uh yeah there's no one to
speak of uh it was a perfect night to
play rugby and i suppose you would have
been the same that sort of gets you
excited that you know we're gonna have a
pretty good
entertaining game of rugby and that's
what happened i remember the kickoff i
don't think it it stopped for a while it
sort of went from side to side everyone
was having a crack and yeah i remember
after sort of five minutes thinking if
we keep this sort of pace up you know
everyone could be out in their feet by
80 minutes so
um yeah that's that's sort of what i
remember from that final yeah mate and
then when the whistle went what was the
feeling like um yeah it was it was
pretty unreal actually i know i like the
cross at you guys and you're pretty
deflated as you should be but hey you
went on to win the one the next year so
but we had the likes of jamie and
brownie and i remember andy watts and a
whole lot of guys that had obviously put
in a lot of work to get us to where we
were but sideline ready for that final
whistle would go and then you know that
that put a lot of time in here for them
and um i was just an awesome feeling
then
you know the boys were pretty um fizzed
up that you know we've done it and then
got into the changing room and then the
likes of your lashes he came in and i
don't know he gave another spiel and
um the boys were charming again and and
then you know shane christie he was full
hollanders kept for the rest of the
night and
we went back to where we were staying
and met family and friends and things
like that and
took the trophy back there and had a had
a good night so
yeah it was definitely one of my uh best
memories of
rugby in general yeah
is that when the sort of bender with
bender started after that
um
yeah i didn't have
that nickname actually came around when
i was playing for green on so um it was
yeah so there was uh
i should have when i first seen that on
that they said i watched your nickname
it was smithy at the time um but they
said oh i don't think they like their
nickname so they there's a guy in that
idea so they called him mattress and so
obviously pretty original those came
from
you know my magnet came from ben but um
yeah i haven't heard that
yeah so you've sort of picked up this
reputation of being
unreal on a bender from just the made-up
nickname
yeah which is probably uh yeah yeah
it's based on the lighting
i'm horrible
oh that was just shane christie and the
kit you didn't follow him for too many
days no no he yeah oh yeah i think he
actually was mixed place uh um
on like a monday or something but um
i do need to talk about your all black
career so i'm pretty keen to hear a
little bit more about that so is it true
that you made the all blacks after one
super season was it yeah so
2009 uh was my first super season and
then yeah i got a got a chance at the
end of your tour so yeah i was sort of
like a young kid really that was going
into that all black environment that was
yeah i suppose rubbing shoulders with
guys like dan carter and richie mccor
and that and yeah
uh yeah i've got a couple of
opportunities at the back end of 2009.
uh we played italy
obviously in italy in milan and that was
that was pretty uh pretty awesome
experience pretty um surreal getting out
there and playing for the all blacks and
uh yeah definitely learnt a lot in that
tour and watch professionals and
and the guys that have played a lot of
tests rugby go about their weekly
schedules and how
organized they were and how they
prepared for test matches and things
like that i think you know that helped
probably progress my own rugby and
learned a lot of off those kind of
players here and when you have a rapid
rise into the all blacks like that um
did you feel comfortable in the
environment or did you feel well out of
your depth
nah i felt real uncomfortable that's for
sure and i think you never are
comfortable in the all black environment
it's one of those environments you're
always on your toes
uh going into that environment uh yeah
it was definitely a mess of uh sort of
shock and
uh yeah i went in there with uh zach
guilford and mike delaney at the time so
yeah
there's three of us that were eyes wide
open going into that and
uh yeah a pretty awesome experience now
looking back at it and we first started
in uh japan uh we played australia in
japan and then moved on to the india
tour it was like a six-week tour yeah
which was um quite a big tour at the
time so
yeah definitely you you never come to
that all black environment and
yeah definitely you see people like mine
on that and
it can be pretty intimidating
um yeah when you first sort of walk into
that sort of environment and
um but at the same time like awesome
learnings awesome that they sort of get
alongside you helped uh progress your
game and then you know you get the best
coaching we had in ted at the time uh
and
steve hansen wayne smith um but you
never never never come to remember when
one of my first trainings i had my socks
down
um just hadn't had like just haven't had
a chance like everything going on i
hadn't had a chance to pull them up and
he saw me just before training he's like
what are you a socks down kind of player
is that is that your character and i
sort of you know
quickly whip my socks up and then
from there i probably just you know
everything that was going on i sort of
double checking things and making sure
that i was doing things right uh that
sort of stuck with me you know just i
suppose like wayne smith always driving
standards and
a little thing like not having your sock
pulled up you know he was calling people
up on it and just always driving
just just little standards and that was
off the field before you even got onto
the training pad yeah so was that even
the back end of your career you still
didn't feel comfortable in there even
though you're all black everyone was
looking up to you oh no like i don't
think you're ever comfortable you always
yeah like there's a lot of like in there
all black environment there's a lot of
pressure on uh the whole team to perform
and
yeah i think the fact that you're never
comfortable in there means that
everyone's the same i suppose i wouldn't
be the first one to say that that yeah
um you're always trying to get your own
process right your preparation
and
uh the way that the coaches set up the
weeks you know in a review and things
like that they're always
pushing the point as to making sure that
we get better even you know after
performing really well against teams and
putting a few points on teams
you're always removing going into the
reviews on a monday because that's
probably where they pick things apart
the most after a good one then
um made sure that yeah
people were accountable and
yeah shag was probably
pretty ruthless at times at a
team review on a monday but you knew it
was always for the benefit of the team
yeah yeah so it was a pretty ruthless
start for you as well obviously that
second year um you weren't picked um did
you get much feedback around that but
then the opportunity came for you to go
to the commonwealth games with new
zealand seven side as well so yeah like
2009
super rugby i was really happy with
how's tracking and then into the um
the npc uh but then
yeah they're all blacks like the
opportunities i've got like i was okay
but i wasn't great and i knew that i had
a lot to work on
in 2010 came back and knew that it was
probably
at that level that i needed to probably
perform at a better level to get more
opportunities going forward so i wasn't
too surprised in 2010 when i didn't make
it it was probably a realization that i
just needed to be better yeah um and
then
i got
an opportunity to go to the commonwealth
games pretty awesome uh
wayne smith sort of i think he
managed to set that up for me and and
talk to touch and say you know i'll be
able to sort of contribute to that
environment and that campaign so
uh yeah i went and went and played
sevens over in delhi there was uh jose
zach
at the time i think they were the same
as me and and on the outer away but with
the all blacks and finally messing was
playing yeah uh so played sevens uh and
yeah one of commonwealth games gold
medal yeah um kurt baker yeah scored a
halibut ride to beat them in the last
sort of last sort of seconds and that
was pretty cool actually and then
seeing how yeah we had like lots of rock
and bullet uh
guys like that the sevens legends that
you know they were awesome and they came
in they brought us into that environment
they made us feel pretty welcome and
then right from the get-go they were
trying to teach us the game of seven so
yeah and we went to we went to uh
because we were sort of acclimatizing to
um the conditions that were going to be
over it in uh delhi we went to dubai
first and it was hot and just such just
ran the [ __ ] out of us so
i remember at one point there's a bit of
shade down one touch line and it was
important to get down that side
if you needed a if you needed that
because uh yeah it was pretty brutal but
it sort of set us up for a good
commonwealth games and
yeah i went through the
um the whole touch regime and and
definitely
uh saw what everyone was talking about
as far as you know how ruthless he was
and preparing his teams and making sure
they're ready for
uh a simmons tournament yeah and how
hard did you find that adjustment to the
seven-man game obviously you'd played a
little bit at queenstown you mentioned
earlier but um not a huge amount and
obviously the conditioning aspect of it
as well
yes i played yeah played a wee bit um
over at that queenstown tournament but i
actually really enjoyed that transition
wee bit more space obviously in sevens a
chance to oh i think when you when you
work on like when you go to sevens it
actually helps coming back to fifteens
um so the conditioning part of it was
massive we we were i reckon going into
delhi we were the best team there as far
as conditioning was and then
off the back of that you know coming
back into 15s was
that really set me up then to um you
know to give 15s another good crack and
um yeah i was pretty lucky to get that
experience of that was my first
experience with the all black sevens was
going to that commonwealth game so i was
lucky that it was an opportunity to play
at a big event like uh the commonwealth
games and
yeah i suppose pretty lucky looking back
that just the timing-wise that i managed
to do that yeah and then the following
year you obviously would have had your
goals set on making that rugby world cup
squad 2011
which unfortunately you did miss out on
that how hard was that one for you to
take yeah well that was a goal um like
everyone else by new zealand yeah i
played rugby in new zealand that was
that was the golden um and and i suppose
you know there was a lot of
excitement that it was back in new
zealand uh there was you know a chance
for us to probably
rectify what had happened in 2007 so
that was it was massive to try and push
for that but it wasn't to be there was
really good outside backs
in
new zealand
in 2011 and yeah just wasn't wasn't my
moment to have a crack in an event like
that so i had to sort of just by my time
and
yeah i was lucky enough and then
following years to get a crack back in
the environment and uh to be able to
then play more tests from there but uh
at the same time awesome to see uh
us as all blacks
perform really well in a tournament like
that
um won the world cup new zealand get
right in behind us
um and yeah it was just different for me
it was
watching in front of the and the tv and
uh having a few beers so yeah but
difference of what i sort of imagined uh
i suppose at the start of 2011 that i'm
you know might have been a chance to to
play but this didn't work out that way
did you ever think about telling um
graeme henry that you could play ten
i would have had to crack it up but um
yeah
yeah might have been an opportunity
might be my only him that yeah but uh
yeah i actually played team back in the
day but i know right if i reckon if
graham henry knew that it might have
been your movie not beavers
yeah he's still reaping the benefits
he's still uh
yeah still cashing in on that day which
is uh good to see deserves that because
he obviously copped away but yeah while
there and then uh good to see him turn
around and um
yeah he deserves everything he gets old
yeah mate he's a champion but for you
fast forwarding four years 2015 world
cup this is where you'd sort of cemented
yourself as an all black and um talk to
me about this rugby world cup for you
yeah 2015 a good year obviously we'd um
we'd manage to beat you boys in the in
the final for the super rugby and
yeah it was yeah we'd had a couple of
good years leading up to that world cup
um 2013 would you know manage to do a
calendar year without um dropping a game
and then yeah there's obviously a lot of
excitement going into that that
tournament it's been you know something
that i've missed out on in 2011 and
there's a lot of pressure being over in
the in the uk but i could imagine that
that was tenfold being back here in new
zealand so it was actually quite good to
get over there
we had a pretty sort of low-key um start
to the tournament and the fact were
there early got a good amount of
training in that wasn't low-key that was
pretty high pressure
the trainings were beating the [ __ ] out
of each other uh for a few weeks there
even when the pool games were going so
yeah
yeah
awesome experience and my family ended
up coming over near the end of pool play
and
yeah hoping that um i suppose we were
going to stay here till the end
otherwise we'd all be picking up our
bags and going home so
yeah that worked out pretty good and
then oh worked out very well and what do
you remember about that final series
yeah i remember france there was
because everyone knew what happened in
2007 there was
definitely a lot of tension going into
that game but i thought we you know we
managed to put that to bed i suppose and
and play really good footy against the
uh the french and yeah i thought we
played a pretty expensive game and then
things started to stick and then i think
you know in the pool play we weren't
actually playing that good at rugby so
when it got to playoffs i think we'd set
ourselves up
really well in the fact of
you know we were really well prepared
and then yeah we got a good performance
against france and then we knew that
south africa were dangerous so we played
them in the semi and we knew it was
going to be a bit different to
that quarter-final and yeah it was i
remember watching at the time it was a
massive shock when japan beat them but
they turned that around and then they
started to perform really well and you
only just scraped through against them
to be fair that sam whitlock stole a
line out sort of 20 meters from our own
line and
that was probably the difference it
wasn't much in it and then all all of a
sudden we were playing aussie in the
final and that was a uh yeah a big week
it sort of felt like it went forever
before that game sort of kicked off and
the final i just remember probably the
start and and the fact that you know
guys like conrad smith and richie and
i everyone really was just teeing off
and and defensively we actually shut
them out for the first five or ten
minutes and
um bodies were sort of being thrown
everywhere
um so that was a big memory of mine
probably um and then yeah i managed to
get 10 in the bin my first yellow card
um a professional breakdown what was it
yeah not a good time to do it in the
world cup final and
i remember sitting on the bench thinking
geezer and they scored two tries when i
was on bench and thinking geez like no i
hope
i hope we get this across the line
because otherwise you know i could be
batman to get back to new zealand here
i'm gonna have to find somewhere else
move the family and
i don't know go a little somewhere else
and apply my apply my trade somewhere
else so
that was scary times that 10 minutes in
the bin uh but
yeah lucky to get back on the field and
we sort of pulled through after that and
managed to
to get it done and then yeah obviously a
couple of good days following that and
getting home and the parades and
everything like that new zealand was
sort of going off and awesome memories
really yeah was that a genuine fear on
the bench that you might not be able to
return home is that where the mine's
going is your mind just racing sitting
there watching that mine was racing yeah
and and you're trying to tell yourself
no i don't don't think like that but um
it does it definitely is
uh thinking yeah where am i going to go
and luckily uh you know conrad smith
came over while i was uh getting that 10
minutes for the yellow card and he came
over and he
he sort of said you know you're all good
don't worry don't stress you know
we're good we've got this and
i it was only like a couple of comments
from him but it meant a lot at the time
because you feel pretty isolated i was
sitting on a chair no one really to talk
to or um to communicate with us then
yeah him just because they were still
staying warm in that and some of the
boys were when we had to come over and
just have a quick yarn you know that's
that's snakey for me he knew the
you know the thoughts that were going
through my head and and
just the top team man really you know
you know snakey pretty well but yeah
definitely scary time sitting on that
bench
right but then you went back on and you
completely made it
for sure because
um contributed to probably the greatest
all black try in the history of the game
um what do you remember about that one
putting that kick through watching body
go
uh yeah i just remember that um drew
mitchell sort of spilled the ball just
sort of popped up uh and then
yeah i didn't know that sort of body was
coming through them at all i just
sort of had a header step and then um
sort of
towed it ahead probably shin kicked in
the head lima would say
um and then uh
yeah and then he just came out of
nowhere like bodhi does and
uh yeah i suppose
that sort of sealed it for us and
from there she was sort of
she was a done deal and then
dc goes and kicks it with his wrong foot
but um
yeah that was yeah awesome awesome uh to
get back out the ospreys after that
yellow card and to be able to
do something in a positive light rather
than being chucked on that bloody chair
for um
for a tip tackle yeah there was uh there
was definitely a better way to finish
and yeah a good couple of days followed
yeah yeah what is what is that next
couple of days like as a all black world
cup winner yeah it was awesome it was uh
i think there was a pretty
cool time in the fact that we got back
to the hotel we were staying we went
just into the team room there was
obviously a lot of family and stuff
around the hotel but it was just an
awesome opportunity to get down in the
team room the world cup was there there
was no real
official stuff the the night after uh
the world cup final so
i quite enjoyed that because it was yeah
there was a lot of bloody pressure on us
to perform well that day and then
to be able to just sit down and have a
couple of bears
um talk about a chat and and sit there
with the world cup
uh that was that was pretty uh
yeah pretty special and and pretty good
times and there i remember like william
epiada was there um because he was a big
part of you know our defense and our
mindset and everything like that and
like people like that he was down in the
team room sharing his stories and
um having a bear or two yeah it was
awesome mate how good and then um fast
forwarding another four years rugby
world cup in japan talk to me about this
campaign and what it was like for you
yeah it was a
a tough campaign for everyone really i
think you know we're tracking pretty
well and the fact that we played ireland
and that in that quarter final and
yeah the boys played pretty well and
then yeah i don't know i i suppose that
mate
looking back maybe that gave us a false
sense of security going into the
semi-final when england were fired up
they you could tell that
you know they were well prepared um they
managed technically to probably be a bit
better than us uh that day and yeah uh i
was running the waters but um i hope for
everyone involved um that game and yeah
a good lesson i suppose and out
preparing teams but they yeah they just
beat us to the punch and everything and
it hurts to say that but um they did and
deserve to go on to the final but um
yeah i would have rather sort of
been running waters on the in the final
and
um watch watch the team go on and and
win but
um it was good to be able to play in the
third and fourth game and play alongside
guys like ryan crotty and
um sonny williams and karen reed and
matt todd and guys like that that had
played their last games as well uh and
then people like you know colesie and
that that i played a lot of rugby with
over the years it was pretty awesome to
be able to finish in that way from for
me
uh although i would have rather i spent
in the final it was um
it was awesome to get one one last
chance in the black jersey and playing
that third and fourth player how hard is
it for you to sort of put your ego aside
and put the team first when you're not
selected in big matches like this where
um you know you've been training so hard
to get this opportunity and then you're
just left out of that squad i'm sure you
felt like you could have contributed to
that game yeah i think my mindset was
like that that whole selection process
that was out of my control so
as soon as i wasn't selected yeah well
there was nothing i could do about it i
was just going on to try and prepare the
the team as well as i could
for those playoff games and
yeah i think everyone in that same space
was the same so i was lucky enough to
have you know crops was the same ryan
crotty was the same so
uh yeah like we had good yarns
through that time and um you know we
both had that same sort of minds here to
to prepare the team really well but at
the same time it hurt um so it was good
to be able to go and and talk to crots
and
let a bit of steam off but then not sort
of try and bring that back into the team
but we we attacked that and and tried to
prepare the team as well as we could and
um yeah like it was a tough one that
england game to um to watch because
yeah everything leading up to that we
prepared really well yeah yeah and when
you're running water in that game like
what sort of messages are you getting is
it pretty intense or is it all pretty
calm cool collected out there it was
actually really calm like fozzie was
giving a lot of messages as to the backs
as to um
you know how we could tactically be a
wee bit better with uh you know they
were they were kicking really smartly uh
and pressuring us and it was a matter of
like how just like a couple of clear
messages but
as to what we could have done better but
yeah at the time uh the coaches were
really calm but yeah it's tough on
because you you're trying to give
the guys everything they need to try and
um turn things around especially because
momentum they had all the momentum they
had
just every you know you've played a lot
of rugby you know when
um things just aren't sticking and and
you feel like you're under the pump and
that was definitely one of those games
that that was the case one thing that
you did also mention is that last game
against wales almost a fairytale way to
go out for you um without it being a
final i guess that was the next next
best thing what a way to what a way to
finish yeah yeah it was a good way to
finish as i said before like having um
all those players that i played a lot of
rugby with uh
that was awesome to
to get one last game in and and to enjoy
it really like yeah i
remember talking to katie and she's just
like you know this is the last time you
get to do it so make sure that you get
out there and enjoy it and i had um
katie and the kids my two oldest were
there at uh in japan my parents were
there um katie's parents were there my
uncle was there
and
that sort of just just sort of
everything fell into place in that game
and the fact that we you know managed to
win uh got a couple meat pies which
always helps
and uh and i think the biggest thing is
we actually just enjoyed that that last
game and yeah it was yeah pretty awesome
actually it did look like that to be
fair as well and
what a what an all black career that you
had um incredible stuff but talk to me
about your next step which somehow you
ended up in poe how did this one come
about
yes i'd actually signed with
i signed with kobe but i couldn't sign
until halfway through 2020. so there was
like a patch of sort of seven or eight
months where i wasn't playing uh because
they obviously had radio retellic and
dan carter on the book so
there was there was no space for anyone
else really
so that meant that i had a period of
eight months where i was doing nothing
so uh poe actually said oh well do you
want to come over and do a short term
sort of a short-term gig and so we
thought what an opportunity to go to
france live there conrad was over there
uh colin slay tom taylor daniel ramsey
so a few kiwis so good kiwi connection
so i got over to poe uh traveled with
the two kids so a bit of a mission at
the time got over there uh conrad
actually picked us up he picked this up
and uh bordeaux and drove us back to poe
uh which was good of them uh and then
yeah everything was a bit of a blur
actually when we first got over so you
know the kids didn't sleep well that
first night conrad knocked on the door
earlier the next day and then i sort of
said i will you know i'll take you to
the club i'm gonna do a medical which
everyone has to do medical when they
first get over there which i thought was
pretty crack up because i went to the
medical and then you know there was just
your joe average um workers there on a
um an exocycle going until they couldn't
go anymore so
and they you know they didn't look like
they were in um
and peak condition so they were sitting
there um toiling away uh and i was
looking at comrade and then i sort of
had a crack on it and
um passed past my medical and then we
went through a few of the sponsors and
and did that kind of thing and then when
i first got turned up i knew that i
wasn't going to play for it was actually
10 days before i was playing the first
game well just must mean over 10 days uh
and then kind of you know said oh well
the club had said look you'll turn out
you get a chance to find your feet and
then we'll we'll get you in there um and
so i went along to training and then
conrad was showing me around the
facility and tell me
and the boys are having a meeting so i
said oh great opportunity to come and uh
come and meet the guys and and come into
the team meeting so i got to the team
meeting uh and they were naming the team
for that weekend and so
the coach got up and and rattled off the
team and then you know got to fall back
and he said one night and so i was
looking at conrad
i'm so severe but at a time here before
before i'm in the max
and uh so
afterwards you know they pulled me aside
and sort of said
you know a couple of days later
and then
yeah i really enjoyed poe but
yeah i had a bit of a rough run there
too really like my first game we played
star fox and i went defend uh a guy but
i couldn't quite get full extension on
my arm and so
i sort of managed to you know cop them
just under the neck but then that sort
of rolled up and just just clicked his
chin yeah i thought that that might be
that might be a penalty and then it
ended up being a red card so that means
i had to go to the judiciary and i said
i went flew from power up to judiciary
so well you know they seemed real
friendly but guys i obviously didn't
speak french where
you know i took the coach up in a
translator everything was going pretty
well i mean we were flying back down to
poe and i heard that i've got four weeks
for it so
that means that mean that i'm missed all
the games are over that christmas uh new
year period which is actually a pretty
cool time to play over there because you
get big crowds they really enjoy it they
get right in behind the team
so i actually missed that sort of first
four weeks and then i played a couple of
games and then covered it up so
that experience probably
uh was what we were really looking
forward to we still got a bit of
traveling and we went to andorra did a
bit of skiing with the kids went to
uh barrett's which was a pretty cool
place to you know go and check out the
beaches and
then got down to san sebastian one
weekend got to bordeaux
to check out the waters and things like
that but
just as things were starting to get good
and the fact that the weather was coming
wide and we had these planes to sort of
trip around europe in the summer uh so
yeah covered sort of stuffed them up and
we ended up doing a sort of five or six
week isolation
uh in france where i moved them with uh
luke and claire whitelock
uh with with katie and the two kids so
they did well to say well come come stay
with us because we did they thought we
didn't want to be too high
[Music]
and his family were right next door so
uh we whacked a hole in the fence and it
sort of became a bit of like communal
living between
uh the family so
and then and then ended up coming home
after that so it was uh yeah it was
interesting times just with coco and
things like that yeah mate that's crazy
and then you're off to japan right yeah
so then i took japan off the back of
that uh at the end of 2020 i ended up
doing the first couple of months by
myself then the family came over things
were still a bit crazy with covert and
the fact that you know you've got to do
the isolations got over there and
we didn't we didn't catch it early on
somehow
we had quite a few cases within the team
and
like the competition got put back to
start with when we got over there
i think there were seven or eight teams
that had covered so they couldn't really
run the competition so we ended up just
just waiting really and then
i just remember it being a whole lot of
isolation which wasn't really what japan
was about lucky enough when i got back
you know we didn't have all those
isolations and things like that and
japan's now starting to open up and
it'll be good for whoever goes over
there now to experience it because it's
going to return to what japan was about
and the fact that you can experience the
culture you can come and go from new
zealand to japan a bit more to see
family and
you know obviously the rugby
hopefully it starts to
just move on with things and the fact
that there's cobra cases those those
guys just get put to the side and they
keep playing the games which will be a
lot easier going forward yeah and how
did you find the rugby in japan how did
it compare to
all your other places um yeah it was a
bit of a eye-opener going from france
and poe where it was
it was probably the game was probably a
week but slow but more physical and a
lot more contact we went to japan and it
was probably opposite and it was a lot
faster but you know you'd go to iraq and
before you know it the ball would be
moved and it would be out of there so i
actually really enjoyed the footy in
japan and the way that it was played
yeah really sort of fast
quick flying game that sort of probably
suited
uh how you know i wanted to play and
also uh watching cabelco stealers over
the years they played a pretty good
brand of rugby so yeah it was obviously
exciting to get over and to experience
that and did your family enjoy japan did
they go the first time yes so they went
the first time uh it was it was really
tough they enjoyed definitely parts of
japan and the fact that you know we
bought a couple of bikes so the kids
were biking down to school
uh got to experience different foods and
things like that and put a test for the
kids see what they would eat and not eat
uh yeah just got a cool experience to
try something else but coverts would
have made it pretty tough and the fact
that it was always
different isolations we would get stuck
for two weeks and they'd be
covered within the school so that would
mean they'd have to sort of stay
um in the apartment and things like that
so that's sort of why we've decided um
that they wouldn't
uh go back this last trip that i did but
they'd get a bit more consistency with
schooling and things like that but i
definitely think going forward uh if we
were to be signing now and going for
another two years it would be a lot
easier for the family to go over and
experience japan the way it should be
and not just japan like the rest of the
world started to open up it was pretty
awesome to see traveling back that you
know things are just sort of starting to
crack on and there's a bit of normality
starting to appear within treble and
things like that hundred percent
sounds like you're definitely going back
there no no
yeah
i have to run that past the boss so
um
i'm pretty pretty awesome yeah
as you know but for you um obviously
we've spoken about you haven't quite
retired yet but when you do retire what
are the plans um yeah so
pretty keen to sort of follow the kids
around and
get them into sport and be real active
and
have a lifestyle where i can
try and uh if they've got something that
i need to go to as far as like a
competition or something to do at the
school camp or something like that i'm
pretty keen to be involved with them
going forward and being able to be
flexible with their lifestyles so that's
that's a big part of what i want to do
but then uh i'm sort of having a devil
within the property market tough times
at the moment but um
i've got a matter of mind david grant
who sort of works at stuart's down here
in a building firm that we're sort of
starting to
do bits and pieces around the place that
i'm very much a novice but starting to
learn how to sort of you know do a bit
of proper development and things like
that so
i'll do a devil in there and remember
seeing that and coaching i'll see where
that leads and and you never know yeah
mate hustling taking over dunedin
property no i don't know about that just
yeah just trying to learn a little bit
more and
yeah i think yeah jamie joseph owns half
of donating so
there's some of some of his property
all right well as always we have gone to
instagram for some questions and we have
had thousands come in for you
um first question how come there's a man
cave sponsored by spates but he doesn't
let the lads in it
tom franklin
oh fancy here he is he's been down there
having a bear um
i've never been invited to banksy's
house so i'm still waiting
[Laughter]
okay next one
does he still have cobwebs on his wallet
yeah very much so it's about it's about
saving money where we can so who was
that from lima lima
it's rex coming from home
have you always been pretty um sensible
with your money you've obviously made a
fair bit throughout your career you're
in a pretty good position coming towards
the end of it uh yeah i've always
thought i knew that
sort of had to try and be a wee bit
smart with the money knowing that
once it turns over and rugby finishes
that hopefully i can sort of as a family
we can sort of set ourselves up going
forward
[Laughter]
okay next one next one is from our major
sponsor swoosh and i know you're on
swish too so
huge opportunity for the listeners to
get a video
the great man himself but if you could
get a video shout out from any celebrity
who would it be and why um any celebrity
i suppose tom brady's a big one for me
he's
uh
he's the greatest of all time in my
books and what he's done especially at
the age he's done it that's that's what
i admire that he's you know into his 40s
he's putting
a lot of time into his recovery how he
plays
it's obvious but um
yeah shut up from from him would be
would be up there mate bit of a
look-alike too hey
[Laughter]
all the time
yeah all the time
all right we'll have to tee that up
video shout out from tom brady he would
be good okay next one hardest plan to
tackle hardest player to tackle i'd
actually go uh pretty old school in the
fact of leila lilian
back in the day i felt um he was he was
tough i don't just think you'd got it
you you'd had him and then he'd slip out
of it and i marked him a few times
especially early on uh and then i think
from super he might have gone overseas
and played but uh yeah i would say him
true and there's a story when um banksy
obviously left you one-on-one with nani
he um just let him run
what do you remember about that
oh that was fall from her
he didn't even make out like he's
gonna yeah
at least put his head in a dark space
and give it a go but he just sort of
stayed on his inside
didn't even look like he wanted to
tackle him and then
yeah i sort of had to put my head in the
spokes and just got
rolls backwards and yeah a bit of a
headache after that
oh classic
yeah it wouldn't be the first time that
he's done that
okay
shane christie must be into him yeah
yeah okay next one how does ben smith
handle pressure uh
i was enjoying wanting to be in big
moments that sort of when i when i
realized that that was
you know a mindset thing that you want
to be in those key moments of key like
important games that mean something and
actually
embracing that that was probably how
i sort of learned to handle pressure um
and it was sort of mainly mental a
mindset and mindset shift and the fact
that you want to be in those moments
that that sort of
that helped me over the years right like
that
okay next one who is just starting all
black fullback 2023 rugby
yeah
that's a tough one johnny barrett's
obviously got to be in the team
somewhere but i just think the way that
uh will jordan's playing
the way that
yeah he counter attacks and managed to
find the try line uh i think you know
with geordie playing a wee bit of twelve
now i'd just about pick will jordan at
fullback and georgia at 12 not the worst
2012 yeah that would be my that's where
i'd go to with that yeah
good stuff okay last question best piece
of advice ben smith has for what a lead
listener ah
oh i think i've uh
my years have played rugby it's now
especially looking back it's actually
enjoying enjoying the ride of playing
the game enjoy little milestones that
you get along the way and enjoy just day
to day things because before you know it
you're like me and
uh look if i am retired you know i'm
just looking back and um
and all that all the moments i've
enjoyed in the game and and there's
obviously been uh games that you've
enjoyed but then there's also just stuff
that happens off the field yeah you know
yeah when i catch up with you know the
guys that i've played with that's sort
of what we are about most probably is
uh things that have happened through the
weeks of
preparing for games and things like that
so that's what i would say
mate i love it it's so true it's about
enjoying that journey not so much where
you're going to end up but that whole
journey
even from schoolboy rugby to like you
said club rugby otago you've been
through it all but that whole journey of
where you get to was such a cool rider
yeah i agree 100 you're going to enjoy
that that's what it's all about and you
certainly did by the sounds of it lots
of benders lots of good times
not not so many lately
but mate really appreciate you coming on
the podcast giving up your time um
you're a legend of the game here in new
zealand and all over the world to be
fair so um it's been cool to go through
your journey and i'm having you on
youtube
thanks for having me on yeah
you're a
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you